Russia's defense Ministry has released
undated footage of Sergey shoigu it's
the first footage that's emerged since
Wagner called for his sacking as its
Fighters marched towards Moscow but
later withdrew
the head of the mercenary group yevgeny
Prague blamed shoigu for starving his
men of Munitions and even launching
attacks on them NATO's Secretary General
says the Wagner mutiny shows Russia's
foreign policy mistakes
the events over the weekend are an
internal Russian matter and yet another
demonstration of the big strategic
mistake that President Putin made with
his legal annexation or his legal
annexation of Crimea and the war against
Ukraine the European Union's top
Diplomat believes instability in a
country with the most nuclear weapons in
the world should concern everyone
it's not a good thing to say that a
nuclear power like Russia can go into
the phase of a political instability
it's also something that has to be taken
into account
and China's foreign Ministry has also
weighed in on the developments
Wagner group you mentioned is Russia's
internal Affair as Russia's friendly
neighbor and comprehensive strategic
partner of coordination for the new era
China supports Russia in maintaining
National stability
precaution was to be banished to Belarus
and was initially understood to have had
charges against him dropped in exchange
but some Russian media are reporting the
Wagner boss remains under investigation
Mike leppel aldazira